how many of you guys like turn-based
games you know the old Final Fantasy
Tactics games if so I think I got a game
for you guys let's get on with the
review
[Music]
what's going on you guys Lord addicts
here coming at you for another review
today we're going to be reviewing the
die filled Chronicles I participated
with this review on the Xbox series X
and I got a lot of things to say about
this you guys know from looking at these
type of reviews that I've done that I
have reviewed a good amount of
turn-based games those old type of Final
Fantasy Tactics and really anything turn
base in general so when I saw this come
up there and you guys know I had a tribe
man and I I got a review code shout out
to Square Enix you know I want to put
that out there they did provide me this
review code but you guys know regardless
who gives me a review code I'm going to
give you guys my honest opinion this
game was developed by you guys know I'm
about to butcher this name it is
LaCrosse or lacrosse I don't know I'm
not particularly sure you guys can
Google it if you want to look more at
the pronunciation of it it was published
by Square Enix and you know I got a lot
of say about this the first thing I
really want to go over is just the
performance of this game I didn't really
see anything drastically wrong with the
performance on this I did play this on
the Xbox series X so I had pretty much
one of the best things to play any type
of game on now I'm sure it plays good on
PC I think this is on the switch so
don't quote me on the switch you guys
need to go ahead and Google what
platform you guys are looking at this on
so you can get a good detail on whether
or not this game runs pretty good that
as far as the performance though I
didn't really have too many hiccups now
occasionally when you would do summons
and stuff sometimes there would be some
frame rate losses but for the most part
this game ran pretty brotherly smooth
the entire game now one thing that I
will bring out is I know people get
upset when I say this and I know that I
do feel entitled when I say this but I
can't help it there's not a lot of this
game that's voice acted now there is a
good amount that's voice acted it's just
when you do anything side related or you
do any kind of side missions anything
that's not the base story or the main
story of this kind of like Canon and
Anime it's all gonna be just random
scribbles when you have to actually read
the text on the screen now I know that
you know for the most part a good
portion of the game has voice acting it
just I feel like we're getting to the
point where this is a 60 game and you
got to keep that in mind and the game
isn't even voice acted you know a lot of
it you do have to read it's just side
missions if you do just the main story
you'll be fine you won't have to really
deal with anything that's not being read
to you now I'm not saying that I can't
read but I do feel like when you raise
that price you do have more expectations
on what you're going to experience in
terms of you know it double A to Triple
A quality game but I do feel like that
that price is what makes it really feel
like this should have been voice acted
the entire game another huge thing that
I didn't like about dial field in a lot
of other games you know dead by daylight
I'm pretty sure it does this unless
they've fixed it since the last time I
played it I don't like when PC games are
converted over to a console without
abandoning completely the mouse type of
format where you can either actually
hover over it I don't want to go on the
parts of the screen where I can't
actually click buttons it makes sense
for a mouse because a mouse could
actually go over a screen but when you
actually have to like manually put the
cursor on the actual tile that you want
to push play or to go to anything
relevant on there now they do have a
thing to where once you're over you can
press down or go to the one below it
it's just like look man if you guys make
a console Port of a PC Central game this
game would work a lot better on PC just
go ahead and give me the actual Port
don't sit there and just get it right
running on the console I wanted to
actually feel like it's a console Port
so that's why you got to make the
infrastructure and the UI run like a
console game that's that's some
nitpicking for the most part it didn't
really bother my experience with it it
was just really annoying now when it
comes to the story The
story okay first off the story takes
place following three life friends as
they pick up arms as hired mercenaries
now this is one of those things where
you look at like Final Fantasy Tactics
you know bravery default well maybe not
bravery default as much but you know
look at like triangle strategy this game
stories took in place pretty much the
majority of it in a war now I've liked
these types of games and Wars I feel
like the story really puts a lot of
tension on it but this particular game I
feel like really put politics front and
center now that's not a bad thing I've
played plenty of these type of games
that have politics in the center of it
but it's something that usually happens
in the world and it's not shoved in your
face I do feel like the story of this
game was too political and I don't mind
political structured games but it's like
look like clearly the focus of this game
is mainly set place in gameplay you know
they want you to move around the map
they want you to actually strategically
really play this game from like a
turn-based style type of game now is it
entirely turn based no but we'll get
more with that into the gameplay but I
do feel like if they would have took a
little bit more of a what's going on in
the wars perspective on this and not
what's going on with who's going to
ascend to who what nations fighting with
what other Nation another issue I didn't
like with this game is when it comes to
the story they didn't really give a
whole lot of building up to the world
before the war starts in this game uh
for instance triangle strategy I just
played that there's a good amount of
that beginning of that game where
they're building up Nations they're
building up people they're showing you
key characters that you might or may not
see further on in the game this game is
pretty much like okay you do this
Mission they do the tutorial they show
you some of the people in the in this
game and they're okay now you're doing
this war you're in this war so when
certain of these people popped up and we
were fighting certain Nations I didn't
really feel attached to them I'm like
okay I don't know who you are I felt
like if they would have did a better job
explaining the world and building this
world at the beginning of the game then
let you go into the war then it would
have made more sense and I would have
actually been more emotionally attached
to some of these people instead of just
killing people I didn't really have any
type of recollection to who they were at
all another thing I'll actually say
about this game it's kind of weird how
they do battles on here now I'm not
going to say that it was horrible or
anything I'm not gonna say that it
ruined my experience but when you
actually fight people in dial field they
just randomly pop up like it's not like
they're coming in from the side of the
map or they're being flown in now some
do have a little bit of lore why they
come in there like there was a couple
battles at the end where people were
literally flying in from the above you
so that made more sense but the majority
of this game is you clear off a field
and then some random sets of enemies up
here and then you clear off that film
and then the map ends feel like they
could have did a lot more with this
gameplay that they have in this game
where they could have did a lot more
building on units and not just bam it's
all over and you know considering the
summons by itself now for those of you
that don't know there are summons in
this game and this game kind of takes a
lot of the lore from Final Fantasy I
there's Muhammad in it that is in the
demo apologize if that's spoiling for
some of you but I feel like the summon
system works well but they didn't do
anything in terms of lore wise building
on these summons now I'm not saying I
want anything drastic but it would have
been nice like Final Fantasy 15 when
you're playing that game they're they're
building these summons with you now I
don't think that game did a huge good
job building someone's but I do feel
like there was a place for the summons
in the world on here it just feels like
an afterthought something that they put
in the game to maybe make it a little
bit easier for a casual audience I feel
like you know these are iconic
characters especially Bahamut Bahamut is
one of the most iconic Final Fantasy
summons in history compared to something
like Ifrit or Sheva so it's just like
you could have did a little bit more
building these summons maybe you fight
them there's a bunch of different things
you could have done and I felt like they
they just lacked it there another thing
that's kind of weird how they did things
in here is just the mission structure in
general you'll be going through the Hub
World which is pretty much your base and
the missions is literally just talking
to people not cool I do think it brings
a little balance to the force a little
bit in terms of money wise because these
missions are easy to do you just talk to
people so you get that money quick but
to me it's like come on man like
actually have some substance behind some
of these missions now some of them do
you'll talk to some then they'll start
another actual mission where there's
actually gameplay involved but I would
say maybe 80 88 of the missions in this
game is just talking to people maybe a
little bit lower maybe 70 30 literally
just talking to people you talk to this
person you talk to that person they give
you some gold maybe a little bit of
experience put some stuff on your clan
points and then that's pretty much how
it is now you know the faction in this
game they actually do have a pretty
decent leveling up system for instance
you know you get some a cook in your
team that will actually level up the way
they cook which will give you perks in
battle you actually have mercenaries and
Merchant missions where you can actually
get better Merchant stuff and you can
get better resource for you know
building weapons skill points and you
know upgrading the actual summons in the
game that they could have did a little
bit better so they have a lot of things
to actually get you enticed and they
have a good reward system in this game
it's just I felt like they had a great
foundation and I don't even think they
built the house wrong it's just you
could have picked a better layout for
the house it's still fun it's still
enjoyable and I'm not even even say the
story is bad I think the story's
possible and like I said I think they
maybe centered or a little bit too much
around political stuff in general so you
couldn't really experience the war that
you're actually in but I do think that
they went out and accomplished what they
wanted to do and I have to get them
kudos for that it's like I said the
story could have did a little bit better
to me and there's a lot of things they
could have done in terms of structuring
the stories that could have did better
as well but you know when it comes to
gameplay I got a lot to talk about when
it comes to the gameplay because the
gameplay on this game is actually pretty
addicting and what I mean by addicting
is like look this isn't the exact type
of style that you would play from a
Final Fantasy Tactics or a bravery
default it is a little bit you know turn
based it's a little bit more freestyle
than your traditional turn base but I do
think that this is a good middle ground
I would prefer The Bravery default in
the Final Fantasy Tactics gameplay but
this was a good second place going to
that there's scale trees to pretty much
anything you could think of they
actually have individual unit skill
trees that it is a little bit less
in-depth in the actual skill tray on the
weapons but I do think it's a nice
little touch to give people a little bit
more incentive to actually grind out
those sections you get those SP points
for actually leveling up your character
and then you get skill tree points and
those are known as SP now let me explain
to you a little bit on the dial Phil
Chronicle and how they like to do stuff
in this game the SP is something that
you get for Unique uh circumstances that
you get during the mission it's kind of
like bonus content that you get for
doing the mission in a certain way the
majority of the time if not every bonus
content that you get on missions is to
either a keep everyone alive never have
anyone fall or B do it in a certain time
limit now for the most part you want to
generally do both you don't want anyone
dying and you don't want anyone to take
so long that you don't get that bone
bonus time limit that you also get now
you'll get the material to make weapons
and you'll also get the skill points
required to level up the actual skills
that are required for that weapon now
everyone has different things now it's
not like one of the class systems I do
prefer the class system I will come out
there openly on that I don't mind this
system I think it was done fairly well
in terms of you know balancing out your
actual individual skill points with the
weapon skills and building the weapon I
think it worked out pretty well and I
think this is a decent system but I
still prefer the job system because I
want to be able to pick and modify who I
want and to do what I want them to do I
want to be able to build a warrior that
has some form of skills related to like
a Time Mage where you can have Auto
haste on now none of that was present in
this game and I don't think that I'm
going to really dock them for not doing
something another game does but I do
feel like what they did here is a solid
foundation and I have to respect them
for because the game is fun one thing I
can really enjoy what they've done with
this combat is they've actually given
you the ability to replay old missions
to level up and what I mean level up is
you can go with these bonus requirements
on these older missions let's say you
messed them up because the crazy part
about this game is those skill points
let's say you never do it in a certain
time limit or people are always dying
you're never getting these skill points
unless you level up the actual entirety
of your clan to get a huge sizable ones
every time you level up so that's the
only time you're going to be leveling
them up so this game actually is very
hard and if you don't play the game the
game wants you to play it so if you
don't do these things and I don't think
they do a good job explaining how you
get these SP or at least additional XPS
if you do these certain missions in a
certain way and they could have did a
little bit better on that I also feel
like they are certain you know life
change qualities that they should have
done here now let me explain to you how
the actual system unit system is set up
so you got primary units and you got
secondary units the cool thing about is
you can mix and match the primary and
secondary pretty much the primary is
going to be the person that's on the
field at all times and you want that
secondary to complement that primary
unit so if you got it like a flying unit
you want that secondary unit to
complement the attacks that primary unit
can do so let's say that you have a unit
that does more damage if there's some
type of ill buff debuff on an opponent
like stun so you want that secondary
unit to be able to actually do a stun
ability so when you do that first attack
you're able to do even more damage
that's the cool thing uh once you get to
a point you end up having what you can
have up to I believe four characters I
can't remember exactly at this point
four characters on the field at once
they each have two people so you know
you have eight people and once you get
more than eight they don't level up
those other players as much and I don't
think they really level them up any I do
feel like these type of games if you
really want to give diversity in terms
of giving options to the player they
should do auto leveling up to the
current levels of the primary party that
you're using for instance if I'm using
these four these eight people and I have
another five people that's never
leveling up nine times out of ten I'm
never going to even remotely try to use
them especially once you get close to
the end of the game and everyone that
you normally use this 10 15 levels
higher than the people that you don't
use why would you ever try to use those
so I do think that they could have did a
little bit of quality Life Changes where
it just Auto levels them to whatever
level your current people are I get it
that might make the game a little bit
easy it is what it is I feel like I'd
rather enjoy being more uh having more
options as far as characters than the
game being easy or not easy I do think
the AI in this game is is kind of dumb
like you can literally be fighting
people in one place and then the people
almost in the Next Room can't hear you
sometimes they'll be a couple feet apart
from each other and they don't hear you
now I'm not saying that it took away
from my experience a lot I think was
funny more than anything because some of
these actual missions are kind of
challenging if you don't actually level
up these characters the way you need to
level them up and play them a very good
skill wise now I'm not going to say it's
like it like Dark Souls type of skill
wise but it is going to frustrate you
sometimes when you're coming very close
to beating an actual Mission and then
some jackass shows up out of nowhere and
guess what they do they make it to where
you actually lose the entire thing
because they killed one thing that was
on the field that you were supposed to
protect and they will actually put
certain units on the left of the map
which is encouraging you to go fight
them on the left of the map but they're
actually setting up the right of the mat
to come and take out that unit the game
kind of designs a way around the way
they think that you're going to be
playing the way that they actually put
the units on the field so I actually
enjoy the fact that this game isn't
exactly easy now I'm not going to say
it's exactly hard either but I think
it's a good balance now obviously that
AI needs to improve if they can do
little updates to make the AI a little
bit better uh Bravo to that now let's
talk about the overall game in general
now this gets like I said to what 60
dollar game now is this worth sixty
dollars I don't know I feel like if you
like these type of games it's definitely
worth 60. I don't think I would pay 60.
I think 40 is a better price point for
this type of game now if you want to
play this because you love these style
games definitely go out and you know
support that thing but if you if you
look into save a little bit of bucks and
you don't know if you should spend this
on something maybe God of War that's
coming out in a couple weeks you know I
think maybe God of War probably be
better money spent now if like I said if
you like these type of games don't let
me divert you to going and getting it go
buy that game we are coming close up to
you know October novemberish we're going
to be having Black Friday here soon this
game will probably be on a discount then
I do think this game is worth 60 dollars
to the people that like these type of
style games now it's not gonna anyone
that was curious in this kind of genre
this game is not going to get you in it
maybe it'll be a little bit better than
like something like tactics because it
does have a little bit more free form
and it's not exactly turn based so you
know I think it's overall good for the
opening person I just don't know if the
60 title is going to be worth you
jumping in this brand they do have some
big names such as Muhammad in here but
it's nothing serious where if you don't
know what's going on you wouldn't even
know what that dragon's name is but
anyway you know when it comes to this
game like I said if you like these type
of games definitely worth 60 if you
don't definitely not and if you're on
the fence you should probably wait as
well the performance on this game was
good I think the story was okay could
have been a lot better if they wouldn't
have focused so much on the politics of
the game and the gameplay is definitely
a very good time with this and I think
the majority of people if you like these
type of any remote to type return based
games you're gonna like this game but
anyway that is the review for you guys
definitely hit that like button if you
guys enjoyed the video you could always
subscribe to this channel we do weekly
podcasts one on every Sunday at 1pm
known as the iron Lords podcast and we
do another podcast well I do another
podcast every Wednesday at 5 PM known as
the attic show and we do reviews on here
as you could tell but yeah that's it
that's my review on the die of filled
Chronicle I actually felt like this is a
pretty solid experience I enjoyed it
shot it again once again to Square Enix
for providing us with the review code
and until the next review this is Lord
addict I'm out of here peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]